[Musique]
voilà l'année elle venait donc nous
rejoindre la série droits que tout à
fait sympathique s'appelle le bas oui le
bar le bar donc messieurs de bach
monsieur le bas balavoine chanteurs
sportifs plus peut-être chanteur quand
même que sportif paris-dakar paris-dakar
oui du tennis comme peu de golf ma
chaîne m'enfin bon donc ça c'est pas
sorti si un peu sportif quoi pas à dakar
deux fois deux fois où ils ont une foi
une foi une foi gagner pas pour gagner
ta jusqu'au bout oui une fois pour moi
gagner oui parce que la première fois
c'est un peu galère on fait 5 jours et
au revoir
la deuxième fois on est allé jusqu'au
bout et pour moi c'est ce que j'appelle
gagner voilà donc ça donne un bol meurt
en faites pas ben non je pense qu'ils
vont le faire sans moi voilà ça je veux
quand même non aujourd'hui non mais je
sais que entre les deux années où j'ai
fait il ya une année où je ne l'ait pas
fait et j'ai eu beaucoup de remords et
je ne prépare donc avoir une fois de
plus beaucoup
d'abord de regret ensuite des remords
alors moi j'ai entendu parler quelque
chose se passe on doit si on doit en
parler
que vous partiez quand même dans les
pays du sahel avec des camions avec des
tâches vous m me crews metal micro aux
oies il est mieux avec des pompes à eau
oui ça va se faire on sait pas encore
c'est à dire que ça va se faire et ce
que j'y serai ou pas je n'en sais rien
fait en tout cas il est évident que si
c'est pas cette fois là ça sera la
suivante mais qu'on va partir en afrique
amené des choses là bas dans les pays
sahéliens niger au mali en mauritanie
aussi et
mais enfin bon on va pas faire un
reportage je suis tout de suite si vous
voulez me on va le faire et puis on le
fera peut-être vous êtes très
sensibilisée par ces problèmes là
j'essaye il ya une chose il ya quelques
autres de vos petits camarades
y'a pas d'héroïsme c'est simplement
qu'on s'est aperçu et on aimerait bien
que les gens s'en aperçoit dans le
temple ou d'ailleurs que finalement
c'est assez facile de s'en occuper c'est
pas tellement c'est pas tellement
compliqué il suffit de le vouloir et c
c'est pas un gros sacrifice comprends
que les gens soient agacés par les
quêtes les charités les machins tout ça
en plus c'est agaçant et pour les gens
d'ici en plus ça manque de dignité pour
les gens de là-bas mais par contre de
faire quelque chose c'est beaucoup plus
simple que qu'il n'y paraît ça serait
bien que les gens se motiver dans ce
sens là d'ailleurs on fait une autre
opération qui s'appelle action écoles
voilà dans les écoles qui en fait la
france michel berger il ya carole
bouquet richard berry ya gérard manset
faire n'est une dizaine et là c'est très
différent c'est un
une idée qui a été issu d'un d'une
opération qui s'appelle school wade qui
a été fait en angleterre aux états unis
qui venait elle même de berneuil du
fameux concert de wembley et ses bottes
geldof est en fait 7
c'est une manière d'aborder le sujet
tout à fait différente c'est ce qu'on
appelle maintenant un peu prétentieuse
mans est pompeusement le développement
des mentalités
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de s'attaquer à
essayer de convaincre les adultes qu'il
faut faire quelque chose bien souvent il
est trop tard parce qu'on a l'esprit un
peu un peu bloqué on n'est pas facile à
modeler alors que les enfants sont
libres et c'est une opération qui va se
faire avec les enfants et s'est plus
présenté sous l'aspect de la charité ou
de l'aide ou ceci ou cela c'est
simplement avez vous envie demain
d'hériter d'un monde comme celui là
c'est à dire d'un monde où il ya 15
millions de gens qui meurent de faim par
en plus à peu près deux milliards de
personnes qui cherchent à quatre pattes
de la nourriture si vous ne faites rien
vous allez hérité de sa et vos enfants
c'est ce que vous leur légré aussi ça ne
pourra aller que de pire en pire
essayer surtout de faire comprendre une
chose nouvelle c'est que il faut
maintenant tout de suite dire oh oh
générations les plus jeunes jeudi 2 les
gamins passent à dire que notre survie
parce que trop peu d'hommes politiques
en parlent pas si évidemment ça les
arrange pas notre survie dépend aussi de
la survie des pays du tiers-monde
parce que si les pays du tiers monde
meurt il y aura plus personne pour nous
acheter ce qu'on fait déjà c'est aussi
vulgaire que ça oui donc c'est plus
aussi héroïque et aussi voyez vous j'ai
du panache je vais en afrique c'est
beaucoup de lucidité c'est dire faites
attention si vous ne faites rien il va y
avoir un retour de manivelle qui va être
beaucoup plus sévère toute façon je
crois que quelques quelles que soient
les motivations je crois que toutes ces
actions de toute façon ne laissant que
positive et je trouve ça tout à fait
bien j'ai juste très content qu'on en
ait parlé voilà
[Musique]